Oh
[Music]
so I've been thinking a lot lately of
the quantified self revolution you've
heard the buzz term it's this idea that
as we extend computation into everything
as we extend sensors into everything
we're increasingly extending those
sensors into ourselves creating a data
rich always-on stream of information
about our biological functioning all the
metrics that we use to measure how this
system of biology is operating are now
getting fed into a machine and we're
pooling the data from millions of people
eventually finding patterns in the data
learning how to optimize the way the
data is managed feeding that information
back into ourselves transforming what it
means to be a human being running in an
optimum capacity you know it and this
just excites me a lot but it because
it's this idea that just like we can
soup up our cars to get more performance
out of them imagine how these insights
into ourselves might transform the
possibilities we can sort of play around
with our biochemical matrix we can
literally
rev ourselves up two ways we could have
never conceived before this can be the
beginning of human 2.0 right
[Music]